c'est à Verneuil-sur-Seine qu'Elisabeth
et Nicolas Soubelet ont décidé d'établir
le siège de leur entreprise ma bonne
étoile depuis 2013 et commercialise des
mini gourde de compote réutilisable les
Squeezie. C'est vraiment une histoire de
famille avec Nicolas on a 5 enfants et
puis un jour on a regardé autour de nous
sur ton notre cuisine et on s'est rendu
compte quand j'étais énormément
d'emballage à usage unique et
particulièrement il y avait un produit
que je vais pas supprimer les petits
pots de compote ça ce constat le couple
se lance dans la création de leur propre
entreprise depuis la naissance de
Squeezie c'est 90 million de gourde je
tape qui ont été économiser on est sur
une route qui qui ressemble tout à fait
une grosse jetable à la différence que
le Front s'ouvre et que tu peux remplir
de soin de compote en gros bocaux comme
ça soit de compote fait-maison mais
aussi de purée de smoothie autre
innovation de l'entreprise l'ébène
Feelgood permettant d'emporter son
déjeuner n'importe où c'est la box sont
fabriqués à partir de plastique végétal
on est parti sur une solution végétal
cirque on utilise un polyéthylène qui
est à base de sucre de canne ça permet
de réduire finalement l'utilisation de
matière fossile
2015 ma bonne étoile est certifié bicorp
un label qui reconnaît les efforts
environnementaux et les effets
bénéfiques de l'entreprise dans le monde
mais la société souhaite dorénavant tu
sais plus de monde et atteindre les
clients de la grande distribution avec
route
on va arriver en grande distribution
donc supermarché hypermarché un autre
objectif de l'entreprise yvelinoise
s'étendre à l'international
à l'international qu'il était pas
forcément très mature sur ce type de
produit exemple l'Amérique du Nord
outre la France ma bonne étoile
distribuer ses produits en Suisse au
Pays-Bas en Belgique et en Allemagne où
elle réalise 35 % de son chiffre
d'affaires